we're living through a very
unprecedented time where I think
fundamentally how we work how we live is
being changed profoundly and one of the
things obviously we are learning a lot
from is digital infrastructure and its
role in what's happening in fact I would
say we're going we will go through three
phases broadly there is the response
phase in which we are acting as digital
first responders to all the other first
responders there is the recovery phase
they're in the midst of the sky you know
talking about what is back to work look
like and of course there is the
reimagine phase because I don't think we
go forward with exactly the same type of
workflows or how we did work or business
process the same way so if you sort of
say digital infrastructure any way you
look at it is going to play a pretty
profound role in fact if there is any
silver lining even on looking back at
our own history as an industry I feel
that resilience of the economy and the
society during this very unprecedented
time is thanks to sort of some of the
modern architectures of things like the
public cloud or the SAS services I mean
when I look at what was it possible for
an educational institution or a company
to go remote and use teams at scale with
all the elasticity wouldn't have been
possible without sort of the
architecture of office 365 or Microsoft
365 or the same thing for a hospital to
be able to provision all of the
telemedicine capacity without a sure so
I think that's good
one of the core priorities for Microsoft
I always go back is in a world where
software is gonna shape pretty much
every industry whether it's healthcare
whether its retail whether it's
education public sector then the most
important thing is let's make software
developers very productive
I would say the most important thing
that we've heard is resilience right I
mean what if you sort of say what's the
top priority for any organization and
all of the professionals that are trying
to create business continuity for that
organization how do you keep the
employees safe and yet at the same time
retain levels of economic activity that
are possible given the current situation
that's what is become a top priority for
them and that means us as a partner
showing up and working alongside them to
create that resilience
it's going to be teams teams teams 75
million daily active users of teams the
keys it's just not video right so the
idea of teams is that I can be on video
I can simultaneously be editing a word
document with you I can be doing
workflow on a business process with you
we can be chatting that ability to
reimagine how people come together to
collaborate to work during the meeting
and after the meeting and before the
meeting that's what I think will unlock
a lot of productivity during even this
remote phase and also when we come back
to work phase there's going to be
tremendous amount of competition there
was competition before there's going to
be competition going forward and all of
us as you said rightfully we have to
innovate and differentiate and customers
will choose and developers will choose
where the opportunity is
yeah I mean we are in fact we are study
I think this is one of the things where
this at scale experiment that we are
doing I think we now first I encourage
our own teams is to one let's get all
the data let's publish the data but let
us not claim too early that these are
long-term trends because I think we need
to be able to sort of really study what
does it mean for productivity even for
example or quite frankly there are some
statistics around productivity right now
especially around github and how we use
even github internally the check-ins the
pull requests and you look at them and
say what people are more productive but
at the same time you got a balance or
what does that mean then with mental
health uh and you need to be able to
have long term metrics because
productivity is not something that is
measured in isolation its measured in
the context of overall well-being of
people and economies and society so I
think we're gonna learn a lot I think
what we are gonna come out of this at
least from my practical even when my own
leadership team is being more mindful so
we said oh wow like you know let's
actually connect and make sure that what
is really how you're feeling what are
your anxious about what do you really
worry about let's make sure that we are
aware of that because I think that
awareness is there as leaders of our
organization and of our co-workers how
do you recreate that mechanism I think
it requires a new type of culture even
there isn't a monolithic way that
Microsoft works
Game Studios work differently developer
you know products work differently a
kernel theme works differently and so
therefore I think we're going to
accommodate for more and more
flexibility of anything what this shows
is let's be even less monolithic and
accommodate for a variety of different
workflows and work styles and
accommodate for it versus being dogmatic
I mean hospital infrastructure the
resilience of that telemedicine remote
learning these were all long-term forces
but if you think about the acceleration
our teachers students administrators
learning in education on how to make
outcomes around education with remote
learning more productive I mean we learn
a lot out of this pace same thing with
telemedicine we've talked about these
for decades but this is the time where
we are not doing it at scale and so the
question is what are we learning what
does it show which is sustainable what
should we reimagine when we get back
quote unquote to normal because
telemedicine as triage I mean one
fascinating example is even in the
covert crisis we've learned a lot about
for example we don't want to overburden
the health care system so you need this
AI triage so we have this health pot
rebuild which is being used by hundreds
of hospitals around the world in their
own applications as the first level of
triage but after the first level of
triage you do need to sort of have a
workflow that chains to a telemedicine
consult and from there to testing so
that ability to build an holistic
solution was all done within multiple
weeks not years and now that it's built
I'm surely get used even in a normal
like I would sort of first go to our
health bot that triage is me then takes
me to an emergency consult and that then
may ask me whether to come to you into a
hospital as an outpatient whether to get
wait for a test kit I think these are
workflows that are going to be relevant
much beyond covert as well
you